so for me this specifically means
learning how nature makes fuel from
sunlight so if nature can do that then
that's a problem that we can solve too
so we'll start this off by looking at
the world at night so obviously this is
a compilation of many pictures of the
world of nights because not all the
world is that night at once but what you
can see in this picture basically where
technology is so we have a lot of
technology and you know the the
Northeast and you know America Western
Europe and there's a lot of places here
that are that are dark so what about
these dark places they're not going to
be dark forever as technology spreads
and increases quality of life for
everybody everywhere these places will
start lighting up there's a lot of dark
on this map so that means that there's
going to be a lot of place they're going
to start out where are we going to get
all that power from our typical the
power of things like fossil fuels you
know your call troll natural gas then
there's a very small fraction of
so-called renewable sort a lot water geo
thermal nuclear and solar which I save
for last because you know you always
save the best for last oh why do I think
Solar is better than all of the other
options well for one wind power if you
wanted to put you have a question
because i'll get to that i get to that
so yeah well i was starting to think
this thing about wind but you know to
get to get a wind-powered or the ones
right now you would need a wind farm
that's bigger than the netherlands so
when water and geothermal are both very
geographically limited you only have a
mincer nuclear isn't really almost
inexhaustible for but then you have and
Three Mile Island and that Jack plant
the light winds places have paid for
hundreds of years so that's why I have a
sad face because people get cancer and
have babies with three offers and all
sorts
fat but solar has none of these problems
so slow learner if it's so great to get
already so one awesome thing about solar
at every second the Sun is supplying
power 100,000 bail perspective on what
hundred thousand terra watts of power
means currently the globe is using about
7,000 terra watts of power go up to
maybe in the range of thirty to fifty
terawatts over the next three years so
tickly the Sun is supplying more than a
thousand times more power than we will
ever conceivably need and if we ever
start exceeding are going to be much
bigger than fine power for everybody so
it's so great why aren't we using it
already well clearly the Sun times
during the day the Deaf day so when the
Sun Goes Down your power strip turns off
you know so step good and then certain
times a year you get a lot more Sun
certain times here you get a lot less
fun so that's bad and then some some
places in this world like where I'm from
Southern California you get a lot more
sun than in some other places like you
know Alaska and then all the sun is
shining sort of everywhere and if you
want something you actually have to kind
of concentrate it down into a very small
spot so basically if we wanted to use
solar energy overall as a power source
for the entire world we have to come up
with a way we have a door that mexi get
around when we want it where we want it
so people in you know Alaska absolutely
screwed when you know it's that time of
year there's fun periods so Rick
batteries is one option maybe your
run-of-the-mill alkaline battery or
maybe a more state-of-the-art toyota
prius battery here there's also fuels
natural gas William Cole so does anybody
know the mileage plug increases how far
you can drive on pure electric battery
power
so the prefatory is apparent 10 to 15
miles Chevy Volt is the best we have
about 50 mott and drive on the strength
of electric power and this is our best
of battery technology this is the best
we got and battery I'm thinking
batteries are not the way to go so we
need to come up with you have your hand
up if we could use the Sun to power the
batteries you know charge the batteries
that would be one option currently we
also feel we have power plants that are
my oh my Mike Mike okay kid missing run
on solar or well you know Leah whenever
we crack that intractable problem yeah
yeah they're not really I don't think
there yeah
yeah there are technologies and
batteries that are not really
commercialized yet that are much better
obviously just like their cars that are
like pull but we not everybody can drive
it's kind of a question of just come
what can you have throughout the globe
anyway so going back to why I don't
think batteries are awesome you know so
few this way we have just you can get a
lot of energy for a small amount of fuel
and yeah thanks guys anyway so what
makes a good fuel why are the fossil
fuels so good let's look at the
structures of the kinds of fuels that we
have from the fossil fuel world we have
natural gas methane with chemical
structure of ch4 or chemical formula
excuse me oil however many seas are in
this particular oil and lots of Ages and
then coal cart lots of hydrogen's so as
you may surmise from this the energy is
stored in those carbon and height bonds
and the the highest density of energy
comes when you have more hydrogen's two
carbon atoms and a particular fuel
molecule so natural gas density of
energy so these fields had to come from
somewhere and it turns out from all
those biomass that died and then fell
into the the dent Center of the Earth
where they were pressure cooked for
billions of years and then turned into
the very simple molecules that I should
put on the previous slide in here so
this is gasoline on your left and
methane on your right but the biomass
had to come from somewhere you know fuel
has energy there's you know one of the
basic principles of the world is that
energy is conserved so the energy had to
come from somewhere and to make the
biomass which then turned into the fuel
so turns out it all came from
photosynthesis so turning sunlight into
fuel so every bit of exegetical ins we
have on this actually came from solar
energy you want no one know why I
believe in solar energy that is why
because it all was solar energy in the
end the overall process of
photosynthesis happens via taking carbon
dioxide and water and then using the
energy of sunlight to combine those
things and to make a bigger structure
from it so
in this case photosynthesis makes
glucose so that's a sugar which then the
plants use to build up bigger structures
like start such which then they form
like cellulose which is a polymer of
this sort of thing which then can
actually make this giant tree and then
it releases oxygen as a waste product
waste products that we're very grateful
for makes our lives possible so all the
biomass in this world came from
synthesis and so did all of our oxygen
so solar energy thing us all of our
fuels so if they gave us all of our
fuels to begin with and there are solar
energy what makes bad you know we have
all this plaque on fossil so what are
the drawbacks of it many people would
say it's because we're running out well
that's not sure we're actually not
writing out as you know about like
fracking and stuff there's really sore
the field available but they're just say
be slightly less accessible but there
are definitely things of yours at least
a fossil fuel around so so the problem
then is that using them has a dark side
and that is greenhouse gases back the
great the fact we throw this around a
lot I think we kind of generally
associate it with getting hotter but why
does it get hotter so in this kind of a
demonstration of why so we have this
lovely earth atmosphere that prevents
the UV light from you know burning us
all to an absolute crisp and so the Sun
radiates with light and a lot of those
wavelengths of light that are actually
useful to us the visible region of the
spectrum is permeable yeah the
atmosphere is permeable to it so it can
actually get into the atmosphere and
then those those rays heat things up on
the earth and then we start to re-emit
radiation so we actually remit radiation
in the infrared region this this light
doesn't actually print so that actually
getting reflected back into the
atmosphere and one characteristic of
infrared light is that it heats things
up
have infrared light heating things up
the more things you have that are
vulnerable to infrared light like carbon
dioxide methane etc the more things you
have warming as a result I and as those
things get trapped then you have them
heating up heating up heating up and
then gets hotter and hotter and harder
global warming disasters so you've
probably experienced the more practical
version of the greenhouse effect your
car windshield is permeable to
wavelengths of visible region of light
but not to the IR radiation so then some
light goes into your car if you things
in your car emit ir radiation can't get
out of the windshield bounces back
bounces back bounces back it gets really
hot yeah oh that's the practical
greenhouse effect them and just imagine
that on a global scale so here keeps up
like her heats up when it's left in the
Sun we really need to solve this problem
so the carbon cycle it's kind of a way
where we we can look to like how how can
you use X so that it doesn't get sent
into the atmosphere so it actually takes
carbon dioxide and fixes it into
something useful like fuel right and
then we the the other side we take
glucose is for a nerd that we really
oxide and also combustion the same thing
so like when we when we take fuels and
then burn them for energy then we also
do the same kind of processes
respiration so so you have a cycle where
photosynthetic organisms fix carbon and
then we unfix it so the problem here is
actually just balance you know it should
be a cycle we should be we should be
using the the things that the plants are
so you know should be sick like the
problem is balance we break more plants
that more fix they spent billions of
years making those fossil fuels and then
we're burning them at you know hugely
rapid rates and so it's kind of like
we're sending more carbon de and then
can handle like drinking fire hose so
it's not good for the plants so
so if we want to you know do a balancing
act here we have to make like a leaf
blur use carbon dioxide for a source of
fuel and so for this people like me
study official photosynthesis where we
use the power of the Sun make no plants
can do it so can we so I look at
photosynthesis and then we try it why
photosynthesis actually how did it do it
it turns out that the central reaction
of it is water Oh two molecules of water
get blasted open by the energy of the
Sun and release their constituent oxygen
atoms and approach and electrons and the
protons and the electrons are both used
for processes in in the plant cells and
see gosh just released as a very useful
waste product for us so this reaction is
really difficult in order to do it it
requires energy and then not only does
it require a lot of energy but it also
has a very complicated path to actually
go through all the way so it requires a
catalyst that can actually take that
path and make it much soon so if we want
to learn how to do this for ourselves
look at how nature does it what kind is
to make this pathway here so these
little manganese oxygen cubes that are
actually nature's catalyst so nature
actually uses this to carry out the
water splitting reaction and it you'd up
with these really cheap material so
manganese dirt cheap calcium dirt cheap
oxygen obviously ever so this is how
this is the what we're trying to do
Thank You American make stew for women
we've tried there was the original
water-splitting catalyst and back in
nineteen eighty moment and the carbon
little later 1991 please manganese law
natural photosynthesis and then I work
on is iridium based catalyst so they're
all you know they're very simple
materials and it should just point out
that a with those ones wait here at ya
in my very own research so we have
catalysts and nature is catalysts what's
the problem you know we have man versus
nature Oh nature wins so turns out that
in order to actually implement this
technology we need something book that
is all cheap sturdy Hannah right now are
catalysts are cheap and sturdy still in
effective or ineffective can only and so
like the supreme it as I showed you the
original very slow barely Kurt reaction
in time scale the fabulous one made out
of manganese that so much like system
well after funds so that's not the term
Bible have a look that I love so much
based on a video element so kind of
expensive more expensive than platinum
for some perspective so not going to be
making a large-scale technology at of
iridium so hopefully do it as you all
know numbers
a lot but we heal and then we turn into
perfectly normal colors with olive oil
Farrell's craziness um so plants are
actually doing this regeneration of
their catalyst every 30 minute fast and
so we have to one-up nature we have to
come up with a material that doesn't
need to heal because do you know of
anything like nonliving things that are
able to heal themselves I don't so we
have to come up with one that is able to
live within that framework that it
doesn't have to heal so this gives us a
mission you know a framework to start
studying so we need to come up with
catalysts that have all of the victims
we need it that's absurd e efficient and
then that's only one part of the problem
water water splitting is part of it but
so is carbon fixation and then so is um
you know actually concentrating the
sunlight in order to power the water
oxidation reaction it all figure it out
then we actually have to make an
infrastructure where we send all this
power out into the world you know it
sounds pretty difficult but you know
what we put a man on the moon when we
want it to you know like like the
politics were like we want to go to the
moon before russia and then we said okay
we'll study science and we'll figure it
out and you know what we owe all this
goes to show that science rocks and you
guys are so for that